usted dice que la respuesta de las
autoridades Fueron insuficientes
cuéntenos por qué
Buenas noches estoy suficiente porque
esta medida por sí sola no va a
solucionar el problema de la migración
irregular ya que una vez controlada a
las personas en su identidad revisada
sus equipajes de todas maneras aquellos
que no son por ejemplo bolivianos van a
ingresar de manera irregular a nuestro
país puesto que la figura de la
reconducción O la devolución al país de
procedencia en este caso no está
operando porque el vecino país de
Bolivia no tiene la voluntad de
recibirlos no así el país vecino de Perú
que sí lo recibe y por otro lado
necesitamos medidas
ejemplares como la expulsión
administrativa masiva porque sería una
señal de ese incentivo para que más
migrantes que se encuentren hoy día en
Bolivia en Perú en Colombia ingresen por
este sector que es de muy difícil
control ya que tenemos 130 kilómetros de
frontera con Bolivia y Lamentablemente
las temperaturas también son muy
extremas señor García usted también pide
una tarjeta de tránsito para los vecinos
de Bolivia Porque es importante este
documento
porque nosotros somos una zona
aymara principalmente donde Hay
comunidades indígenas y que hay pueblos
que fueron divididos por ambos estados
por razones geopolíticas lo cual
requiere de que los estados que han
firmado el convenio 169 de la oit
establezcan un mecanismo Expedito de
tránsito ya que tenemos alumnos
bolivianos que cruzan diariamente la
frontera para asistir a sus clases en
nuestra comuna como también adultos
mayores que cursan hacia Bolivia para
poder adquirir productos de primera
necesidad esa realidad cultural y
también ancestral debe ser respetada en
la implementación de cualquier medida de
restricción implementada por el estado y
ahora cuéntenos a qué situaciones por
ejemplo se ven enfrentados los migrantes
que llegan hasta sus territorios
Lamentablemente los migrantes que llegan
al altiplano sufren las temperaturas
bajas del invierno y por supuesto
mucha deshidratación
necesitan muchas veces apoyo médico el
cual nosotros las entregamos y llegan
con hambre con falta de abrigo Y por
supuesto muchas personas llegan con
problemas de salud